[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón con nosotros Daniela
que bueno tenerla por acá vamos a hablar
de la Nueva Era Twitter que comienza con
los despidos de los principales
ejecutivos es precisamente Raúl eso fue
lo primero que hizo hoy con la
plataforma de redes sociales realizar
varios despidos concretamente a su
director ejecutivo para que grabo a él
al vicepresidente financiero y a la
directora jurídica vijaya gade a esta
última se le atribuyen decisiones de
alto calibre Como por ejemplo la
suspensión permanente de la cuenta del
ex presidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump Y cómo han sido las primeras
reacciones Dani Pues fue el mismo dueño
de textla quien informó a través de
Twitter que había consumado el trato el
pájaro está liberado tu tío haciendo
referencia al logo de la empresa en una
aparente guiño a su deseo de ver que la
compañía tenga menos límites de
contenido de inmediato le respondieron
las autoridades regulatorias en Europa
el pájaro vola trabajo nuestras reglas
tú y yo el jefe de industria de la Unión
Europea thierry bretón
estaba haciendo muy acertadamente era
simplemente recordar Cuál es el marco
que debe cumplir cualquier empresa que
opere en Europa
hay ciertas actividades que no cumplen
con las normas reglamentos y leyes de
los estados miembros
en particular cosas relacionadas con el
discurso de odio actividades delictivas
terrorismo etcétera
Dani Cómo fue la evolución de Twitter en
todo este recorrido pues puedo resumirlo
de la siguiente manera Y es que el trato
terminó beneficiando a ilon musk porque
cuando anunció su intención de comprarla
que fue en abril costaba mucho menos de
lo que cuesta hoy en la bolsa de Nueva
York Cuando comenzó esta saga Twitter
más que una acción de la empresa en Wall
Street costaba 45 dólares y él ofreció
54,2 dólares como una forma de compensar
los accionistas con un pago extra en
plata Blanca la empresa que en ese
momento costaba 33 mil millones de
dólares por el impulso que ha tenido la
acción ahora hoy cuesta casi 41,000
millones una diferencia de apenas tres
mil millones frente al valor que se
comprometió a pagar Bueno y al frente de
esta compañía Cuáles serían esos nuevos
objetivos de aquí en adelante bueno es
que esta fue la parte fácil gastarse los
44 mil millones de dólares Bueno aunque
también tiene que ver cuál es la
financiación Pues ahora el presidente
ejecutivo de tesla debe demostrar Por
qué cree que Twitter vale 10 veces esa
cantidad el autoproclamado absolutista
de la libertad de expresión ha dicho que
quiere evitar que la plataforma se
convierta en una cámara de eco para el
odio y la división otros objetivos
incluyen querer derrotar a los robots de
spam en Twitter y hacer que los
algoritmos que determinan Cómo se
presenta el contenido a sus usuarios
estén disponibles públicamente también
han dicho que planea recortar puestos de
trabajo dejando a los 7.500 empleados
preocupados por su futuro y que
devolvería al aire las cuentas que han
sido suspendidas como por ejemplo la del
ex presidente Donald Trump quien ha
dicho que no gracias no quiere volver
Pero por otro lado hay incertidumbre
sobre lo que pueda pasar con los
anunciantes No pues en 2019
Moscú tuiteó Odio la publicidad hoy tres
años después en la víspera del cierre
del acuerdo apeló directamente a los
anunciantes en un tweet en el que les
dijo que aspira va a ser la plataforma
de publicidad más respetada del mundo
sin embargo de una manera algo
contradictoria Antes había dicho que se
iba a alejar de los anunciantes y que
iba a apostar más por otros ingresos
como por ejemplo las suscripciones hoy
el 90% de la caja de Twitter viene
precisamente de la publicidad y no
solamente de Twitter Sino de todas las
tecnológicas prácticamente
Quién es el hilo musk empresario Digamos
como una radiografía de él Bueno pues
este emprendedor tecnológico cuyo
patrimonio ne de casi 222 mil millones
de dólares según la revista Forbes ha
fundado cofundado o lidera varias
empresas comenzó en 1998 con la firma de
pagos electrónicos PayPal holdings
después dejó la empresa siguió en 2002
con spacex que diseña y fabrica
tecnología aeroespacial y que espera
llevar vuelos comerciales al espacio
continuó con tesla en 2003 que está
dedicada a la fabricación de vehículos
eléctricos y es quizás la más importante
de su portafolio también Tuvo una
empresa de investigación para crear
Inteligencia artificial y neuralink que
es un chip cerebral que conecta humanos
y computadores la última que fundó fue
de boring Company para construir túneles
y que también es su comercializadora de
artículos que van desde gorras hasta
tequilas y perfumes bueno todo un mega
empresario Dani como siempre Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica hasta el lunes nos vemos la
próxima semana la próxima semana con más
economía y nosotros entonces
Vamos hasta París ahí se encuentra
nuestro periodista Luis Miguel Cabrera